Our DNA contains the instructions for
making all of the proteins in our
bodies. Watch "What is a Protein?" to
learn about the different things
proteins can do. So how do we get from
DNA to proteins? This flow of
information is known as the central
dogma of biology. A section of DNA that
contains the instructions to make one
protein is called a gene. A complex
machine called the ribosome needs to
read the instructions and use them to
build the protein. But there is a
problem. The DNA is huge and stuck
inside the nucleus of the cell, while
the ribosome is outside the nucleus.
Since the DNA can't leave the nucleus,
the cell makes a copy of just the
instructions for one protein. The
copying process is called transcription,
and a molecule similar to DNA, called
RNA, is used to make the copy. This
piece of RNA is small enough to leave
the nucleus and bring the instructions
to the ribosome. The ribosome reads the
instructions and builds the protein in
a process called translation. So in the
central dogma of biology, we say that
information flows from DNA to RNA to
protein. To learn more about how
transcription and translation work,
click here.